hey 42 here the Sun contains 99.85% of
all the mass in our solar system welcome
to RIF one in five people in Singapore
is a millionaire making it the city with
the most millionaires per capita on
April Fool's Day of 2007 Google sent an
email out to all its employees warning
that a Python was loose in the
facilities it wasn't a joke
the dairy associations huge success with
the campaign got milk
prompted them to expand advertising to
Mexico
it was soon brought to their attention
that the Spanish translation red are you
lactating a giraffe can kill a lion with
one swift kick Albert Einstein couldn't
speak fluently when he was 9 his parents
40 might be every day more
money is printed for monopolies than the
US Treasury to produce a single pound of
honey a single bill would have to visit
2 million flowers just like fingerprints
everyone has a unique tongue print
before the eraser was invented bread was
used to remove pencil marks and finally
if you whip your head back and forth you
will lose 24 brain cells per whip thanks
for the view subscribe for more 42